oh j'ai frappé à cette porte dans mon
sommeil
combattre la lueur de la cheminée j'ai
frappé à cette porte dans mon sommeil
trouver la lueur de la cheminée
pour m'éloigner me
tenir éveillé de
la maison
et papa prends le fusil de sa place
au-dessus  les portes françaises ils viennent
des bois oh ils
courent toi aussi
et j'ai noué ta langue en un signe de tête
oh j'ai noué ta langue en un nœud
pour envelopper cette journée
pour envelopper cette mort  un drap
et papa récupère le fusil de sa place
au dessus des portes françaises ils viennent
des bois oh ils viennent
des bois
et maman tu cours
et frère je suis tellement désolé que tu
je ne puisse pas cacher le  il y avait
trop de bottes lourdes il y
avait trop de
bottes
lourdes il y avait trop de
bottes lourdes
trop de grosses bottes noires et il y avait
trop de petits marrons  Des chaussures qui
défilent
alors je compte jusqu'au ciel oh je le
compte jusqu'au ciel
face au manque